Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, for this week’s
Game of Thrones Video I’m going to talk
about the top 5 flashbacks I want the show
to do.
Just to explain, Dan and Dave we doing an
interview recently and they owned up to the
fact season 5 would start with a flashback.
Not necessarily the first scene of episode
1, but the first episode will have a flashback
in it.
I think it will probably be one of Bran’s
Godswood flashbacks, but they also said flashbacks
plural, as in multiple flashbacks during season
5.
So that opens it up a bit in terms of what
they can show.
While I was making this video, two new characters
were cast so I’ll explain who they are at
the end of the video.
And heads up, this week is a special giveaway
for copies of World of Ice and Fire I’ll
also explain at the end.
Careful for spoilers through season 4, here
are the top 5 flashbacks I want to see:
Number 5 - Bloodraven Flashback
This one isn’t as likely to happen but it
would be awesome to see the past from the
bloodraven’s perspective also known as the
three eyed rave.
He’s the one training Bran in the cave.
He was a big part of the first Blackfyre Rebellion
and eventually became a lord commander of
the Night’s Watch before completely embracing
his role as the last Greenseer where we see
him right now.
That’s a lot of Westerosi history he’s
seen.
If the show were to expand his part the show
could deal with some pre-show events in a
way that hasn’t been done in the novels.
But Bran is the main character, so of the
two of them, I think any Greensight flashbacks
would probably come from him.
Number 4 - White Walkers In Flashback
If they decide to go with a more traditional
flashback route, characters speaking about
past events and showing them as if they were
memories.
It would be awesome to get a look at any of
the notable events between the White Walkers
and the people of westeros.
There are several moments in history including
the Long Night, The Night’s King, The Building
of the Wall and their gradual re-emergence
before the events on the show.
When we first saw them in season 1, they had
already started replenishing their army.
The term flashback implies a great deal of
time though.
So if they do flashback to some white walker
related event, it would be before the younger
cast members were alive.
It would be like an Old Nan story flashback.
Most of her stories dealt with legends.
Which may or may
not be true.
Number 3 - Doran Martell Flashback
This is pretty unlikely, but I do believe
there is a Dornish Master plan of sorts and
it would be fun for Doran to explain it as
we watch it begin and unfold.
For the most part, the Master Plan is a pseudo
revenge plot tied with an attempted coup.
I’m sure you’ve all seen versions of theories
about it but a flashback would be a really
easy way for the show to cut through a lot
of the misconceptions and simplify everything.
Typically the show simplifies the book plot,
either by cutting stuff out or combining things.
Alexander Siddig or Doctor Bashir, however
you want to think about him will probably
get an expanded part.
In the books there are way more characters
so there’s less time to spend with him.
But the show is changing a lot of the plot
so that they can spend more time with the
Martell characters in Dorne.
I don’t want to get crazy with spoilers
or anything, but I posted a picture to facebook
and twitter yesterday that pretty much explains
what’s going on.
So if you want to check it out I’l add a
link in the description.
Number 2 - Maggy The Frog
This is the name of a person and the name
of a prophecy related to Cersei.
Maggy was a fortuneteller in Lannisport when
Jaime and Cersei were little kids.
During a big tournament being held nearby
Cersei visited Maggy with two of her friends
to get their future’s read.
Maggy gave Cersei some very ominous news.
It’s also believed that Cersei murdered
one of those friends because she wanted to
get married to Jaime someday.
It just adds a darker spin to Cersei’s character
and the murder part was only implied, it wasn’t
explicit.
Right now in present day, Tywin Lannister
is dead and Varys has fled the city, so there’s
no one to tell Cersei what to do.
She can rule as Queen regent without any interference.
So she will get a lot more screentime.
The Maggy Prophecy and the event itself could
be used to give her behavoir in season 5 some
more context.
I spent a whole bonus video explaining the
Maggy the Frog Prophecy so I’ll include
a link in the description if you want to learn
more.
But I would love for them to flashback to
a prophecy related moment.
Number 1 - Ned Stark Winterfell Flashback
Bran is currently with the Three Eyed Raven
learning about Greensight.
We got a little teaser for what that looks
like.
Like when touches the weirwood tree and has
visions of the Giant Weirwood with the cave.
They might change the visual effect for it
to make it look a little cooler, but I think
that’s what the greensight scenes will look
like.
They might drain some of the color out in
flashback moments.
Greensight is one of the more broad abilities
but the cool part is getting to see across
time.
It’s localized to weirwood trees though.
So Bran and the Three eyed raven would only
be able to see historical events inside Godswoods
like the one in Winterfell.
So there’s a small chance we could get a
Ned Stark flashback.
Regardless of who you think the most important
character is right now, I feel like Ned is
a character that everyone can agree they want
to see again in some way.
I’ve seen most of you in the comments say
you’d like to see him as a wight.
But I don’t think that will happen.
Ned spent a lot of time in the godswood at
winterfell, not just as an adult, but when
he was growing up.
So Bran theoretically could see what he was
doing.
Dan and Dan said there would be multiple flashbacks,
so they could do any number of moments.
I do think it’s most likely they’ll use
Bran to do the flashbacks since it’s a part
of his abilities.
But there are a lot of fan favorite moments
like Robert’s Rebellion that people want
to see, so they could always deviate from
the books and show whatever they want.
We do have little bit of info about that first
episode.
We know that Bran is in it for a little bit,
we don’t know what he’s doing, but if
they’re doing a flashback in the first episode
and Bran has scenes.
It’s possible they’ll open the season
with a Ned Stark moment.
That’s just a theory.
But let me know which flashbacks you want
to see.
Just remember, it would probably involve characters
that have been featured on the show.
And the other really big news is that they
just cast two more actors, Mr Eko from Lost
is going to be a character named Malko.
We don’t have any other details about him
but he’s not a character from the book.
Based on his looks it’s possible he could
be featured in one of the eastern cities.
There have been sets spotted for Illyrio’s
house in Pentos, Meereen of course because
Daenerys or he could show up in Dorne.
Then other new person is Gwyenth Keyworth.
She was on Misfits with Ramsay Bolton.
She won’t be a Bolton character though.
Her name in season 5 will be Clea and she’s
playing a Whore that Tyrion has some scenes
with.
As an actress she’s known for her foul mouth
and quick wit, but we dont’ really know
where she’ll be meeting with tyrion.
His boat with Varys was headed east, so probably
in Pentos or wherever the boat lands.
Varys and Illyrio were conspiring together,
so it’s possible he could take Tyrion there
first.
Since my video schedule is changing a little
I’m probably going to try and stick with
Thursdays or Friday’s for Game of Thrones
bonus videos, feel free to leave me requests
for topics.
My next one will probably drill down on one
or two of the bigger prophecies I like.
Be sure to subscribe to get that.
And don’t forget, the giveaway for the next
couple of weeks will be for pre-orders of
the World of Ice and Fire book.
That’s a hardback, so it’s almost like
you’re winning two giveaways at the same
time.
I’ll announce the winner when I post next
week’s video.
Right now click here to learn more about the
Cersei Prophecy and a few of my other favorites
and click here to learn more about my top
5 character pairings in season 4.
Thanks for watching, now let’s all high
five and I’ll see you guys tomorrow.